des femmes du département mises à
l'honneur au château de Versailles pour
sa première édition le Prix des pluriel
organisé par le collectif uvinois de
l'Académie des pluriels a réuni des
dizaines de personnalités féminines des
Yvelines
une de mettre en lumière des femmes qui
agissent au niveau local au niveau de
leur ville au niveau de leur immeuble au
niveau de leur quartier donc là il
s'agissait aujourd'hui à Versailles
voilà de les mettre en valeur et de leur
faire aussi prendre conscience que ce
qu'elles font à une grande valeur
l'événement a été construit en
partenariat avec des associations et les
mairies de trois communes des Yvelines
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Mantes-la-Ville et
Les Mureaux une élection sans candidate
et son jury sans jury parce que personne
ne ne ne
sélectionne réellement à partir d'un
dossier ou il y a pas de il y a pas de
concours en revanche ce sont les femmes
entre elles une fois qu'elles sont
dominées pour finalistes se sont elles
qui définissent et qui choisissent qui
sont les lauréates en fonction de
critères qu'elle même définissent
entre 18 mars Journée du droit des
femmes 12 finalistes ont été honorés
c'est un grand jour et
et c'est un bel événement que nous
vivons surtout qu'on a été honoré dans
ce beau château et c'est juste une
pierre voilà l'objectif est également de
créer un réseau solidaire de femmes sur
le territoire
en fait tout simplement c'est l'idée
c'est de créer une synergie le Collectif
Citoyen veut désormais renouveler
l'expérience pour une deuxième édition
les fondateurs visent plus loin espèrent
développer dans les prochaines années le
prix pluriel au niveau national
[Musique]